[Music]
I'm Sergeant Benjamin Harris United
States Army infantryman
I was 26 my daughter was born two months
before we deployed
it's in those first couple days certain
details I can remember very clearly and
then certain things that I would think I
remember I don't remember at all it's
like a puzzle and I don't necessarily
know the order of a lot of the things I
remember I just remember they happened
wasn't until that day that I realized
the potential of being out with a 20 guy
Patrol and being surrounded by 30 or
30,000 that's when I get security
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was when it got real for me I
wasn't ready for the mental side of it
that first time that that you realized
these people are trying to kill me that
was really hard for me to accept at
first
and they're gonna do whatever it takes
even if it means that you kill them
first
[Music]
and then kids started getting involved
that that's my nightmare that they used
kids to fight against us I never
expected to be in that situation
I don't think there's any way to be
ready for that
[Music]
a kid 10:12 that was running back and
forth across the alley firing at us
that was my first instance of seeing
kids shoot at us and I remember very
clearly shooting back and very shortly
thereafter I can't say exactly how long
a slightly older man coming out and
dragging the body away crying and coming
back and picking up the weapon pointed
at us was was getting ready to fire
he went down and an older man probably
in his 50s came out and started to drag
his body away and then picked up the a K
and turned towards us and started a shoe
[Music]
I remember sitting up there thinking I
just killed three generations of a
family
[Music]
it takes a long time with some of the
stuff to finally accept everything that
happened
somebody handed a ten or twelve year old
kid in a K in magazines and said here go
do that
I have thought about that kid every day
since
because I look at my children and I
think you know he was 10 years old then
he would be 23 now what would he be
doing with his life because you're
making a choice between you or the guy
next to you or that kid it's the most
permanent thing ever
whether or not I made the right decision
it will never feel right to me
[Music]
acceptance takes a long time the last
year or so specifically I've come a long
ways towards being a home within
yourself reaching home is reaching that
point where you're comfortable in your
own skin after everything that happened
and that long road is the process that
it takes to get there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]